that's the first surprise and and and um
that is very special to have lisa on the
show so i don't want to take care away
from that but now lala
you're gonna tell everybody what the
surprise
that you're gonna surprise lisa with oh
i'm like shaking right now because i
can't believe that it's a real life
thing
i'm really emotional i know it's okay
let me gather
my self by the way so everybody knows if
you're not watching this podcast or any
snippets of it
lala has tears flowing over her eyes
like i cry about everything
but today it's very much happy tears by
the way today is my 30th birthday and i
can't think of
any other way to celebrate
uh celebrate then with you guys coming
through your
headphones and speakers um and for my
30th birthday
i had the best gift given to me
my body also helped out too um i am
pregnant
a soon to be mother i
am and i'm like so excited i feel
very maternal and motherly and um
it's just i feel it's
very interesting and i'm gonna try not
to ball my eyes out i cry about
everything by the way tim
like i look in the refrigerator and it
could be empty or full and i'm like
happy or sad about it